c'est donc un message de soutien que je
suis venu délivrer aujourd'hui et pour
le reste nous réserverons nos
interventions au tribunal je dis ce que
j'avais à dire j'ai essayé d'être le
plus sincère possible par rapport à la
situation par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé Air France et Airbus sont sur le
banc des prévenus les deux entreprises
sont jugées pour homicide involontaire
dans ce qui est aujourd'hui l'une des
pires catastrophes de l'aéronautique
européenne le 1er juin 2009 le vol AF447
reliant Rio de Janeiro et Paris
s'écrasait en pleine nuit quelques
heures après son décollage
216 passagers et 12 membres de
l'équipage ont péri c'est la catastrophe
la plus meurtrière de l'histoire d'Air
France les premiers débris de l'Airbus
330 ainsi que les corps ont rapidement
été retrouvés mais c'est seulement deux
ans plus tard que les pas et les boîtes
noires ont été épicées après de 4000
mètres de profondeur après 5 phases de
recherche sous-marines elle révèlerait
que les pilotes avaient été désorientés
par le givrage des sondes et qu'il
n'avait pas pu rattraper le décrochage
de la pareille qui a l'air et la mer en
moins de 5 minutes
comme expliqué ces tragédies les pilotes
ont-ils commis des fautes était-il assez
formés des questions qui continuent de
hanter les familles des victimes ce
procès va permettre de de toucher du
doigt en fin la vérité sur cet accident
pour quelle raison il s'est abîmé en mer
pour quelles raisons leurs proches les
228 personnes qui se trouvaient à bord
sont des CD
en septembre 2019 le tribunal de grande
instance de Paris avait déjà tranché
dans ce dossier ordonnant un non-lieu en
faveur d'Air France et d'Airbus les
jugés ne pas avoir retenu de charge
suffisante contre les deux entreprises
les proches des victimes ont fait appel
de cette décision celle-ci a été
renversée en 2021 laissons place à ce
procès ici Daniel Piaggio Radio-Canada
Montréal